hey guys how's it going so I just saw
that there was some new updated news
about the new iPhone 7 there's some
leaked images so we're gonna take a
quick peek and see what we can see it's
been a while since I made any iPhone or
Apple news videos because I've been
traveling so most of the past videos
that you've seen or all travel vlogs
let's see what we can find about the new
iPhone 7 this is the image that
everyone's been going crazy about it
says if you're wondering what the iPhone
7 should look like when it's more than
just a bare shell covered in watermarks
look no further here from Engadget they
hole that's a big hole it also looks to
be photoshopped to be honest with you
let's open this in Photoshop and just do
a little inspection like that doesn't it
just doesn't feel this doesn't feel it
feels really not not sure here's a
little trick that I use sometimes just
see if somebody does a good Photoshop
job or not if you up the highlights you
can sometimes see that they completely
miss the boat and do not give a good job
of making sure that everything is
perfectly smooth and color corrected the
shot doesn't verify any other rumored
details such as the lack of a headphone
jack little sim support or increase
storage clearly you're not gonna be able
to tell if there's an increased storage
on a phone that has zero markings at all
it's all we have is this it give me all
the iPhone 7 news you guys have iPhone 7
looks hotter than ever a new leaked what
looks hotter than ever like this is such
a harsh shadow I'm hoping that these
white vans around here is not actually a
thing I mean granted we all end up
covering our phones up with cases so
you're not even gonna see it anyway I
mean I guess this doesn't even look that
good either to be honest with you I
forgot I even had a gold phone I also
have a privacy screen on my phone if
you're wondering why there's sort of
like this little black ridge around it
pretty incredible let me give you a
first example you can see it now now you
can't see it see it now
now you can't now you see it no you
don't I'll put a link in the description
if you guys are interested in getting
one of those not sponsored it just
obsessed let me what you guys think of
the comments below
I feel like this
so faked this also doesn't look like the
two-tone flash that they've been doing
before maybe they found a way to sort of
integrate it into one so if you look
like iPhone 6s plus this is the two-tone
flash that they have so if you have a
newer phone you probably already have
the slash integrated into your camera I
just feel like this doesn't look real at
all that outer glow that they put on
this just doesn't do it for me I was
faking this this is what I would have
done this is not this is like they did a
terrible job at this this is not even
good look at this this is a garbage
Photoshop job right here this all is not
even even it's almost like they just
took this phone and basically took this
bottom part and flip it and put it up
here into this Israel that I'm sorry but
it's not it I'm not happy about it
I also feel like we should add a little
bit of a camera so you can actually see
I just feel like anytime I'm looking at
this if I'm actually looking at it right
here I can still see the ones of the
camera so let's just take a little piece
of the lens and add that in as well oh
that looks great
Oh looks real great let's just turn this
down a little more Italy it's not
perfect because I just did this in a few
seconds but I just do not like a few
things about this this just doesn't feel
right to me this doesn't feel right that
shadow drives me crazy I feel like there
should be less although if it is super
protruded I guess you might be able to
see that much outer rim shadow I'm not
sure
honestly who knows and sometimes I ask
myself for Justine why do you actually
care I'm not even sure we might as well
just wait until September we can get the
truth I feel like in a month or two
we'll probably actually have the truth
look if you guys have any other iPhone
news or anything else that you might
have heard feel free to leave in the
comments below or tweet it to me
and I'll see you guys in the next video
right there is a pokey stop of we gotta
we gotta get up